years since we launched idea of Xbox
right here at Gamescom because of our
belief in the power of independent games
since then we've been blown away by the
creativity and innovation independent
developers are bringing to Xbox there
are more than 1,000 studios creating
games via ID at Xbox today and it's
awesome to see how many are also
starting to take advantage of xbox live
on Windows 10 in fact every game I talk
about today will ship on both Xbox one
and Windows 10 so getting started we
want to talk about one game we've been
excited about since it was announced
this spring I'd like to welcome to the
stage a true master of game design
please welcome the crater of Castlevania
Symphony of the night mr. koji Igarashi
to talk about bloodstains
hi everyone
wonderful economist Oliver brought the
stain to no windows team ban me its name
Copa modern coke model in his name Xbox
one no clothes frame key naugahyde
ricotta was necessary Thomas hello
everyone this is Iike as you can see
he's still working on his whip cracking
skills today gives us great pleasure to
announce cross Play functionality in the
Xbox one and Windows 10 versions of
blood-stained ritual of the night
breathlessly enjoy this next one into
scenter practice to eat or dismay he
tango the Yokosuka no tanzaku gotta
action-rpg day
chiku status named gotengo medium it is
necessary to write a tighter anonymous
for those of you who do not know
blood-stained ritual of the night is a
2.5 d side-scrolling action adventure
game with heavy RPG elements it recently
raised over 5.5 million dollars on
Kickstarter hey kudos plane yo to this
new mix look so I knew that Windows 10
users net towards any predict a mistake
in Prato staying on this net okay
because a guy countess named Yuri
tanoshiku a taken three predicaments
cross-play will allow Xbox one in
Windows 10 gamers to enjoy and explore
the deep vast
robust and gothic world of blood-stained
together mortals
concrete is net total supply though you
a semester we actually have one other
small surprise for you today
yeah tell us she can also customize that
one was a little bit better a brand new
character it stained the comic Alex
TARDIS named toto is a key that's cooked
on oh there it is Nina my Tokaido madam
you can see on top regard in desierto mo
a the game no City no Jew name my needs
met so can Sarita
a comet a toaster demo honto stories
we're still putting the finishing
touches on this character so we don't
actually have an official name yet but
week
and say that this is a demon hunter that
fights the demons that first come to
earth on an attack that occurs ten years
before blood stain the game begins
oh we need a snifter foodie no katana
toe okay let's cut the top economist we
can also say that he is a dual sword
welding hero that uses Japanese or Fuda
spells to fight his phone's conquer
Microsoft Atacama stated I wanna cross
prayojana a car taking out his name and
or a chayote code aikidoka quantonium
que es como dreamers and we're just
really really excited to be able to team
up with Microsoft and prepare such an
innovative cutting-edge feature for all
of our fans una semana para tosse Tendo
achieves demo hack we dedicate any
corticon welcome but this is XD genis
thanks for everything guys we're working
our best to try and get the game into
everyone's hands as soon as possible
thank you very much Cheers awesome
it's a back